- And there seems to be no sign
of intelligent life anywhere.
- Hello!
(light upbeat music)
- [Narrator] This November,
"Toy Story" celebrates
its 25-year anniversary.
The beloved animated adventure
of toy box allegiances
was the first feature length
film released by Pixar.
Since 1995, the studio has gone on
to win 16 Academy Awards,
11 Grammy Awards,
and 10 Golden Globe Awards.
But did you know that the first
computer animated movie
studio was once owned
by Star Wars' George Lucas
and Apple's Steve Jobs?
Or that their first initial breaks
included Star Trek and Listerine?
You will!
Join us as we take a look back
at the history of Pixar,
to infinity and beyond!
Pixar started 16 years prior to releasing
its first feature length film
when George Lucas recruited Ed Catmull
to lead Lucasfilm's Computer Division,
Lucas had already worked with Catmull
whose company Triple-I
had made the X-wing
fighter for "Star Wars."
Simply called the Graphics
Group at that time,
what Lucas wanted from this arrangement
was advancements in digital film editing
and digital sound editing.
By 1982, Graphics Group completed
the first completely
computer animated sequence
ever made for a feature film in
"Star Trek II: The Wrath of Khan."
The scene in question was
a terraforming sequence
by the Genesis Device,
where we witness a lifeless planet
suddenly transform in simulation.
In 1984, the studio created
its first short film called
"The Adventures of Andre and Wally B."
Combining hand-painted textures
with flexible
computer-generated characters,
this would be the first example
of character animation done by computers.
The Graphics Group completed one more
feature film sequence for George Lucas,
the stained-glass knight
in "Young Sherlock Holmes,"
before Steve Jobs purchased
the company in 1986,
one year after being
ousted from MacIntosh.
Jobs bought the Graphics
Group for $5 million
and was the largest
shareholder in the company
until Disney purchased Pixar in 2006.
It was under Jobs that
Pixar first got its name,
a combination of "pixer,"
a made up Spanish word
that sounded like "to make pictures,"
and "radar" for its futuristic learnings.
But it also became the company
that we think of today,
because this was also when the Pixar lamp
was first introduced in
the short film, "Luxo Jr."
For the first five years
as an independent animation company,
Pixar completed a number of shorts
including 1988's "Tin Toy"
and 1989's "Knick Knack,"
which saw them making large leaps
in three-dimensional movement.
By 1991, Pixar also made commercials
for Trident and Listerine.
It was the commercial work
that allowed them to hire
future film directors
Andrew Stanton and Pete Docter.
It was also the commercial work pipeline
that showed the studio could work
with outside clients
and this led to Pixar's
first agreement with Disney,
signed in 1991,
"to make and distribute at least
"one computer-generated animated movie."
That first film, of course,
would become "Toy Story."
"Toy Story" was the perfect
story for Pixar in 1995
because their technology
made all organic objects look plastic,
which was ideal for a story concerning
the active life of toys
when humans are not around.
The human rendering was so far behind
that originally the filmmakers
hoped to avoid showing humans altogether,
outside of limbs.
but early on faces for the Davis family
and Sid, the evil neighbor,
were deemed necessary for the audience.
Though the human characters
look off to us now,
this only highlights the
monumental achievements
that Pixar has done in advancing
its own technology through the years.
Stanton shaped the story as a buddy movie
and the writing team,
including Joss Whedon, Alec
Sokolow, and Joel Co-hen,
added sarcasm that was atypical
for animated movies at the time.
- I'm just a couple of blocks away.
- [Slinky] If Woody says
it's all right then,
well darn it, it's good enough for me.
- I don't believe that man's
ever been to medical school.
- Do we have to hold hands?
- You guys think this is a big joke!
- [Narrator] Pixar decided
to avoid musical numbers
to differentiate itself
from Disney proper.
However, production would be shut down
to retool Woody's character
to make him more likable.
- Wait a minute.
You don't think I meant to
knock Buzz out the window,
do you Potato Head?
- That's Mr. Potato Head to you,
you backstabbing murderer.
- [Narrator] Stanton tasked the writers
to make Woody and Buzz engaging enough
that if an audience
"were stuck in an elevator
with them for 70 minutes
"it would still be entertaining."
The resulting film, released in 1995,
was the highest-grossing film of 1995
at $192 million domestic
and $361 million worldwide,
far eclipsing Jobs' expectation
that it would break even
if it grossed $75 million.
Pixar's next film, "A Bug's Life,"
allowed the company to further
its 3D character mapping
via a world without humans,
and "Monsters, Inc." allowed them
to animate many different shapes
and improve upon their human forms.
The directive at Pixar
was to create a
computer-animated environment
that had not done before
and thus, the team went underwater
with "Finding Nemo" in 2003.
- [Group] Fish are friends, not food.
- Except stinking dolphins.
- Dolphins?
Yeah, they think they're so cute.
"Oh, look at me.
"I'm a flipping little dolphin.
"Let me flip for you.
"Ain't I something?"
- [Narrator] In 2004, Pixar's
next landmark achievement
was the three-dimensional human form
in "The Incredibles,"
which then blew the door
off the type of stories Pixar could tell.
- Honey!
- [Honey] What?
- Where's my super suit?
- Where is my super suit!
- [Narrator] I put it away.
- Where!
- [Honey] Why do you need to know?
- I need it!
- [Narrator] Following that
film's massive success,
in 2006 the animation studio
was formally sold to
Disney for $7.4 billion.
Since "The Incredibles,"
Pixar has created the digital worlds
of Radiator Springs in "Cars,"
a French restaurant in "Ratatouille,"
outer space in "WALL-E,"
into the sky in "Up's" balloon house,
to Scotland in "Brave,"
to the Jurassic era in
"The Good Dinosaur,"
inside a child's brain in "Inside Out,"
into the afterlife in "Coco,"
and a world of mythical
creatures in "Onward."
Over the past 25 years,
there have been eight sequels
to five original franchises.
"The Incredibles II" has been the biggest
success at the box office
with $1.2 billion earned worldwide
and "WALL-E" holds the record
for most Oscar nominations
for a Pixar movie at six.
All told, Pixar has earned $14.5 billion
at the worldwide box office
in addition to all those golden statues.
Because of the COVID pandemic,
their next original film, "Soul,"
will be released on Disney Plus
but there are four additional
theatrical Pixar movies in the works
with releases in 2021, 2022, and 2023.
However, only Enrico Casarosa's
"Luca" has a title and plot
as of this video's publication date.
Set in a beautiful seaside town
on the Italian Riveria
where all is idyllic,
except for the sea monster
that lives offshore.
"Luca" will be Pixar's
24th feature length film.
So, of all of Pixar's releases,
which is your favorite?
Tell us in the comments below.